Pete Chatmon, Director/Podcaster/Author:I
hated that job because I probably made 50
to 100 phone calls a day but when it came time
five years later to raise money for my film.
Film Courage: Pete the first
chapter of your book TRANSITIONS:
A Director’s Journey and Motivational Handbook
by Pete Chatmon starts with how to quit.
What is this and why is that
important to start the book?
Pete: One of the things that I wanted
to keep in mind with the book was that
I don't want to be prescriptive in saying this
is the way you have to do it and I also didn't
want to be overwhelming to the reader in a sense
of like you got to figure out you've got to know
what you want to do every nook and cranny
of your career needs to be decided and then
just attack it because I know that it can take
people various amounts of time to figure out
what their voice might, be what their sensibility
might be, what their appetite for whatever
different position you might seek in the industry
requires of you. I wanted to in the beginning
speak about curiosity and how much of a benefit
or a plus it is to have that because if you're
not curious I think you start to become a little
too cemented in what you think works and does not
work and it's constantly evolving and in route
to figuring out what you want to do specifically
you're going to have to quit and so I wanted to
hopefully present that to the reader in a way that
it's not a derogatory word to quit in fact when
you choose to quit it's an empowering thing
so if you are walking down a road of let's
say you're you're editing and you're like
editing's not for me and you pivot from
editing to writing or editing to producing
that that quitting can be a positive thing
so it's kind of my opportunity to rebrand
the energy around the word quitting and is
there quitting with finesse and quitting with
burning your bridges that's a great question I
think that you can definitely quit with finesse
I think when it's clear what your goals are then I
think I maybe found the right word or another word
for it which is a pivot I think I think quitting
can be just a pivot but I also think you can burn
you can end up burning bridges if you do it if
you don't dismount gracefully what so I think
the idea is to not burn any
bridges because you never know
when you're going to run into people again and
I think a lot of what we do in the industry
is built upon relationships so burning them
down is probably not going to be in your favor
but sometimes that can be hard not to right
because I'm thinking if if let's suppose
there's personality differences but it's better
to as I like how you say it dismount gracefully
that might be difficult and especially if
there's an ego at the top and so egos at the
top tend to know each other and could make
phone calls so yeah just how you dismount
and making sure no one's pride is hurt that's a
difficult thing in any industry I would imagine
yeah it is I feel like another thing that
I've come to try and add to my process
it's like certain relationships are going to be
and by I'm speaking more specifically to like
positions on a crew are going to be contentious
by virtue of the fact of what each position is
empowered to do right so like an easy example
is like a cinematographer wants more equipment
to beautifully capture the show and a producer is
wanting to get the best look for the least amount
of money and so if we if these two parties know
that then they can already accept that it's going
to be a lot of no's and a lot of whys and a lot
of seemingly contentious exchanges it but if it's
going to be like that you can get past that and
kind of just have the conversation you need to
or maybe find a way to embrace it with humor
because we're all just doing what we I hopefully
we're all just doing what the job requires
of us like if I want another take at a scene
hopefully the actors know that I'm not doing it
for any reason other than I'm trying to get the
best out of this moment but then on the flip if
an actor feels like they don't have another take
to give and and they think that we've got it and
it seems like they're really not willing to do
another one what I have to make a decision on my
end too and so it's always this kind of frequent
navigation of the interpersonal dynamics that
you have to find finesse in and I think maybe
as people get older they realize okay I need to do
the two weeks notice or even a month or have the
talk and let them know I'm going to be leaving but
I think when we're younger and I'm speaking from
my own experience there are times when you just
go okay cool it's lunch time I won't be coming
back and and you think that okay I'm 21 it's not
going to matter right but maybe just don't take
that interning job it's not something I probably
could have taken at that age but if you can't
stay with it and and a lot of times the the jobs
we come across that we don't enjoy oftentimes like
there are periods of time right like like it might
be a three-month commitment or it's the duration
of this film sometimes it's can you get through
it is there anything else you can learn outside
of the thing that you'd rather not be dealing
with can you learn the inner workings of how
a film is produced while being in that office that
has a few people that aren't your type of people
what like can you can you find
the the value to take away from it
a lot of times it's reconfiguring your perspective
to get something guaranteed to propel you forward
right and did anyone question you about that
chapter or did people praise you like well that's
great that's a great way to start a book about
it yeah I think people I think there's a sense
of relief and I hope there's a sense of relief
for people who read it and they're like okay
yeah that's I can I don't I'm not about to read a
book that's going to tell me here's what you need
to do and blah blah blah it's going to help me
find help me develop some tools through which to
employ as I move toward finding my path so
the response has been great I think it sets
the tone that it's going to be
more reality based rather than
just I don't know all these cliches that you hear
for years but that that okay stuff is temporary
and it may not always be a fit and that's
okay and you may not be able to fix it right
right so do you think that there's a time
limit on how long to stay with the job now I
realize it's different because tv directing
and it's short-term projects usually but
yeah that's a great question I guess so is there
a time limit for how long to stay with a job
I feel like a lot of what happens in I'm
gonna take film and tv and try and marry
those the types of jobs that people have a lot
of times they're they're p they're freelance
driven or they're kind of periodic so they kind of
have their own time limits where if you're on a if
you're editing a film it's I don't know why I keep
using editing but if you're editing a film it's 12
to 18 weeks of your life and then you can move
to the next one tv show nine months maybe fewer
if you're a producer that project is gonna project
may never go or it may it may be a small window in
time and then maybe you didn't have a good time
on it but they make a sequel and you back out of
it because you want to have whatever peace of mind
you're looking for so I feel like we have a unique
opportunity in this creative space to
not be married to anything too long
so you can find a way to withdraw or
not continue without having to quit
but if and when that thing that situation arises
it's it's really measuring what's the what's the
real benefit I will say if there's questions of
of like mental health if there's questions of like
it's just an improper situation then by all means
like talk to the proper people and and withdraw
yourself from anything that's not good for you
but I think finding that being too ideal about
how the work experience should be can also leave
one missing out from the benefits that they could
take from a particular job because I can tell you
like if I go through the jobs that I've had over
my career not many of them were awesome but what
but a lot but I but they're like I can always go
back and say oh I learned that thing from that
job and then who knew that four years later
i'd be able to take that thing and and turn it
into something that powered what I was doing one
of my first jobs out of college was working for
a company that would kind of soon be over taken
by imdb but this was a company that you had to pay
for the information that is available for free now
and I had to call i'd read the trades hollywood
reporter variety i'd look at the film markets
me fed american film market whatever it was and
I would then call and say oh it says that you
bought the rights to this book is it true are you
making this movie what status is it in when it
might you begin shooting it whatever and I hated
that job because I probably made 50 to 100 phone
calls a day but when it came time five years later
to raise money for my film my feature I built a
muscle up of like I can talk to anybody because
it's just a conversation until they tell me no
I don't want to invest in your project I
have no problem following up because that's
just kind of this thing that it was the byproduct
of what I had done begrudgingly for two years
that's fascinating was that the book that was in
blockbuster I well it was called baseline studio
systems and I don't know I think it was all
they I imagine they probably had some physical
resource that you got but I believe it existed
online and then you just subscribed to it and
got whatever you got but that's how that I dealt
with one little process of it I don't even know
what people got on the other end of their of their
payment right oh that's fascinating so then you'd
had people hang up and and you'd already sort
of been that the hazing of any telemarketer
you probably already yeah okay that's gonna happen
fine oh you don't because they're and then they're
on the flip there will be people would be like I'm
calling for my 900th attempt to update this record
because after x amount of time we're going
to check to see like should we make this a
a like a dead record or is it active and
so you're calling people and it's like
the production company somewhere in North Carolina
and it's the same guy you've called eight times
and it's like hey how you been and they're
telling you a little bit more about the trials
and tribulations of making the film and you're
building these relationships in a in a weird way
that's fascinating wow and so that that must
have really helped I'm sure yeah then you then
you're not scared yeah yeah and just wrapping
up so it sounds like with most jobs if I were
an hr manager and I looked at a resume with
all these different projects i'd be like oh
wow you've you've jumped around a bit but in
the film industry it sounds like that's a plus
yeah I would I imagine so I've been very kind of
tunnel driven with with my career pursuits but I
do know like friends that I've had in advertising
in the commercial world it was shared with me that
it almost looked bad if you stayed somewhere
longer than two to three years because then
I guess what they were saying is that it looks
like you're stagnant or it looks like you're not
seeking to try new ideas and then communicate in
a different way or you're not well sought after
so there's all these little each industry kind
of has its own take on the activity of a resume.